shopping spree in downtown summerlin and  help for a great cause today a grand  prize winner was announced in the lights  for flights experience benefiting  miracle flights they are an organization  helping fly sick children to distant  medical care lisa dixon went home with a  2500 gift card as part of the promotion  illuminated signs are placed throughout  the downtown summerlin area encouraging  donate donations to that nonprofit  families have told us they want this to  be part of their holiday season going  forward so we expect to be here every  year and in fact we're still here  through early january  so far we are told miracle flights has  achieved more than 140  000 flights for those families and it  really is an essential service when you  think about what they're bringing them  to undergo